>>> THANK YOU.
>> OKAY, I'LL SEND YOU WHAT I
OWE YOU RIGHT NOW.
>> WITH SERVICES LIKE VENMO AND
APPLE PAY, THERE ARE SO MANY
WAYS TO SEND MONEY IN AN
INSTANT.
>> JUST GOT IT RIGHT NOW,
THANKS.
>> WHILE CONVENIENCE IS GREAT,
DON'T FORGET, THERE'S ALSO --
>> CHEQUES.
BECAUSE THERE'S NOTHING LIKE
FURIOUSLY SCRIBBLING ON A PIECE
OF PAPER, CARRYING IT, FLICKING
YOUR WRIST AND SAYING, I TRUST
THIS WILL SUFFICE.
>> USE CHEQUES FOR ALL YOUR
PAYMENT NEEDS.
INCLUDING, MAKING HIM LEAVE YOUR
DAUGHTER.
>> TAKE THIS.
TAKE THIS AND NEVER COME BACK!
DON'T PICK UP HER CALLS.
SHE WILL BE HEARTBROKEN BUT IT
NEEDS TO BE DONE.
>> FORGET WHATEVER YOU THINK YOU
SAW LAST NIGHT BY THE GAZEBO.
>> USE CHEQUES FOR THINGS LIKE
PETER'S BIRTHDAY.
>> FOR TAKING MY RINGS OFF AT
NIGHT.
>> CHEQUES.
>> BUYING POISON.
>> JUST ONE SIP AND I BECOME
HEAD OF THE BOARD.
>> BEST OF ALL, CHEQUES ARE
EASY.
>> HERE -- WHAT DAY IT IS.
HERE -- HIS NAME.
HERE -- HOW MUCH.
HERE -- THE SAME BUT IN LETTERS.
AND HERE IS THE SECRET.
>> CHEQUES.
>> A CHEQUE IS DRAMA.
A CHEQUE IS A PROMISE.
GET THEM IN BASEBALL, DAFFY DUCK
OR MICHIGAN STATE.
AND MAKE SURE TO ADD THE DASH
AFTER THE AMOUNT OR GOD KNOWS
HOW MANY ZEROS THEY'LL ADD.
>> CHEQUES!
>> AVAILABLE AT RIDGEWOOD
SAVINGS BANK.